los detalles empiezan desde que el ex
abogado
se declara culpable por haberle pagado a
la actriz porno stormi danius 130.000
dólares para mantenerla callada sobre el
supuesto romance que tuvieron en el 2006
el expresidente Donald Trump y la actriz
porno esto días antes de que finalizara
la campaña en del 2016 a la presidencia
el ex abogado dijo que él había tenido
que sacar dinero de su bolsillo estos
130 mil dólares para pagarle a la actriz
porno y que después el expresidente le
repagó este dinero pero que a la hora de
declarar los gastos de campaña puso este
dinero como honorarios legales y ahí
estaría el delito por la cual sería
condenado el expresidente y por la cual
pues se dicen propia expresidente y
autoridades ya en Nueva York se están
preparando precisamente para lo que
sería la llegada del expresidente a
Nueva York y el posible arresto arresto
que pues ya muchos dicen y empiezan a
cuestionarse sería entonces traído a el
a a a a las oficinas legales en Nueva
York a la corte del distrito de
Manhattan esposado entonces hay ya en
pie en varios operativos también de
seguridad para pues proteger a la ciudad
y proteger estos estos establecimientos
legales en Nueva York